bonsoir bonsoir je suis très très
admiratif du témoignage de géraldine je
trouve que c'est vraiment extraordinaire
de se mettre à nu devant vous comme ça
et elle nous manque vraiment comment on
peut dépasser les frontières c'est ça je
vais vous parler des frontières mais
c'est plutôt d'un autre type de
frontières moi je suis arrivé en france
la première fois en janvier 1995
je suis arrivé avec un échange erasmus
comme comme un étudiant j'avais à peu
près votre âge et j'ai décidé de rester
pour faire un stage en janvier 1995 en
italien qui voulait rester en france
pour faire un stage avait besoin de ça
un permis de séjour a fait obtenir ces
permis de séjour
c'était un parcours de combattant je me
souviens de plusieurs rendez vous à la
préfecture
il manquait toujours un papier on me
demandait toujours de nouveaux papiers
comment et pas demandé auparavant une
fois on m'a convoqué en préfecture
seulement pour mes paires signé un bleu
un document qui j'avais fini un noir
janvier 1995
en mars 1995 les accords de schengen
arrive tout c'est énorme montagne
administratif fond comme neige au soleil
en fait tout ça a été complètement
inutiles pour l'administration française
je n'étais plus un étranger
je n'étais plus en migrant italien gt1
resortissants européen dix années après
en fait à l'âge de 30 ans je disais j'ai
décidé de quitter mon travail de
consultant en stratégie d'entreprise et
je décide de faire de ma passion pour la
photographie
mon métier peut-être ça pourrait être le
thème d'un autre ttoc une autre fois
mais restons sur une sur salle donc je
suis photographe documentaire et je
décide de documenter de notre société de
notre monde
je pense à cette expérience et je dis il
faut faire quelque chose en fait
il faut parler des accords de schengen
de la liberté de circulation en europe
c'est incroyable ce qui nous arrive
c'est unique dans l'histoire de l'europe
et tombe sur cette photographie d' harry
cartier bresson le poste de douanes de
bayonne à la frontière entre la france
et la belgique
ces postes de douane parle de mon
expérience en fait parce qu'à l'époque
il y avait encore des douaniers quand je
suis arrivé en france la première fois
en 2007
j'ai par un peu un pèlerinage à la
recherche de ces postes et one je le
retrouve complètement abandonné la
peinture écaillée je me dis tiens et un
truc là il faut que je fasse quelque
chose
au début je pense je vais faire un sujet
sur tous les postes de douane abandonné
en europe et je commence avec un premier
voyage long de la frontière de la france
voici le premier poste de douane que je
retrouve imposé douanes reconverti en
boutique de chocolats
je me dis c'est génialement série va
être extraordinaire j'aurais et les plus
beaux postes de douane au monde a fait
ces photos c'est la seule peut-être des
postes de douane parce que tous les
autres étaient abandonnées en fait
complètement délabrée dans mon triste en
fait il parlait plutôt de l'europe du
passé moi ce qui m'intéressait en fait
c'était parler du présent et donc j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à la ligne de
frontière j'ai décidé dans chacune des
mes images
il y aura deux pays et donc la ligne de
frontière comme ici entre la frontière à
la frontière entre la france et de la
suisse
tout ce qui reste de la frontière dans
cette photo cc point de jambes sur le
bitume
des fois la frontière on la voit pas
comme ici entre la france et l'allemagne
je suis sur le château de fleckenstein
et la frontière un peu paumé dans les
bois mais alors vous allez me demander
mais pourquoi infecté tu t'intéresses à
la frontière qu'est ce qui te motive à
travailler sur ça aussi les résultats
dans google images d'une recherche du
mot frontières aujourd'hui quand on tape
le mot frontières sur internet
voici ce qu'on voit une succession
infinie des murs des barbelés des postes
de douane des migrants est ce que cette
représentation est fidèle de la réalité
le géographe français michel foucher a
calculé que au monde seulement 6% des
frontières sont des barrières
94% défendirent au monde ces deux
classes ce2 de passage il frontières par
définition est un lieu de passage
mais alors je me suis dit mais ça
ressemble leur croix en fait c'est 94%
c'est quoi c'est ça qui m'a mené ce
repaire des dix ans à explorer ça
j'avais envie de voir un image qu'est ce
que c'est une frontière en fait ces
voyages c'est un voyage extraordinaire
ça m'a amené à voir les frontières par
exemple les vampires les plus anciennes
de l'europe
et si on est entre le portugal et
l'espagne ses frontières est presque
inchangé depuis le xiiie siècle jusqu'à
les aux frontières les plus récentes
ici on est entre la république tchèque
et la slovaquie
ces frontières existe seulement
officiellement depuis 1993
d'ailleurs suite à la seule révolution
connaît en europe sa mort la révolution
de velours
je suis monté jusqu'au nord de l'europe
ici et je suis entre la suède et la
finlande
là le cannabis est la première zone en
europe avec une zone de libre
circulation qui déjà en place depuis les
années 50 pour les arrivées jusqu'au sud
de l'europe dans des lieux vraiment
reculer ici on est à la frontière entre
la bulgarie et la grèce dans le village
de coggia petit village presque en
autarcie
à quelques mètres de la frontière avec
la grèce j'ai vu des endroits